from bali fields in the australian state
of victoria
to beijing and now to the world trade
organization in geneva
china has imposed tariffs of 80 on
australian bali
effectively halting the billion dollar
trade it was the largest market for
these farmers
australia is calling foul and for the
first time
asking the world trade organization to
intervene
we along with many other countries use
these processes
in the right and orderly way and
australian industries should see this as
being
about australia defending the values
operation and interests of australian
producers
but doing so in a calm methodical
and careful manner china insists
australia is breaching wto rules
it argues that australian farmers
produce barley with government subsidies
and sell it below cost so should be
subject to anti-dumping duties
we have said multiple times that some
discriminatory practices by australia
against chinese companies go against
relevant international norms
the australian government should take
chinese concerns seriously
and take concrete action to correct
discriminatory actions against chinese
companies
china is australia's largest trade
partner with two-way trade totaling
nearly 200 billion dollars last year
but diplomatic relations have
deteriorated and with it trade
it worsened after australia rallied
international support for a u.n inquiry
into the origins of the coronavirus
since then it has escalated further with
a
range of trade measures it's not just
barley it's tourists it's wine
it's coal even lobsters cotton sugar
so it's quite sharp now between the two
countries
well the world trade organization will
act as a referee for china and australia
a result will take time potentially
years
in the meantime china is piling tariffs
on australian goods
and canberra is searching for new
markets charlotte ballas
al jazeera